[Music]
ann is with us in oklahoma city hi ann
how are you
hi babe thank you for all you do well
thank you how can we help today well i
want to give you a scenario and my
question will be how should i best spend
almost 200 000 in inheritance that i'm
about to receive and best help my
retirement and not be a burden to my
children one day and also be able to
retire well here's my scenario i'll soon
be 60 years old i was divorced in early
2021 after many years of marriage
my net worth is approximately 600 000
excluding the 200 000 inheritance
i have no debt
out of that um
out of that 600 only about 34 of that is
in retirement savings account the rest
is in rental properties and a small
business that i own
i have a fully funded emergency fund
my yearly bring home pay is
approximately 96 000.
5000 of that comes from the business
each month and 100 comes from
part of my teacher's retirement and
rental property income
i've been renting for a little over two
years and i've never had my own home i
would love to have a condo or a small
home
and i was wondering what the inheritance
money
should i try to buy a small condo or
home with cash if there's anything left
over invested in mutual funds
or should i forego buying and just put
all of that 200 in mutual funds
and let it grow
um you know interest and all my concern
there is if prices keep arising will i
ever be able to afford my own little
place
or do you have a different scenario you
might recommend
well you are really on top of this
you have done a great job of knowing
where you are
and that tells me you really have
probably a pretty good plan of where
you're going
um how much longer do you plan to work
well you know
at least till probably 65 i mean i would
love to retire at 65 but i don't know if
that's realistic um you know 65 67 is
possible
uh you know
what kind of uh what kind of business do
you own
it's a little closing business boutique
is it brick and
mortar uh yeah yeah
okay
well as long as it remains viable i'd
probably continue to run it as long as
you want to
um and what i would do is begin to get
more and more management involved so you
have more and more time off as you
uh go past 67. but there's no reason it
can't continue to produce an income for
you up into your 70s
okay you could sell it at some point if
you wanted to just quit
but um my guess is what you're doing is
not that physically straining and you
don't sound like you're stressed out by
it
no okay
so i i think i think i'm gonna continue
to operate as long as i can there's no
rule that says you have to quit working
at any point especially if you enjoy
what you're doing and i got a feeling
with all you've been through that it it
probably is a bit of a
an escape area an area you can go that's
that you won't that you can control the
variables a safe place yes
yes it's a wonderful place we're very
grateful to be there yeah amen yeah okay
yeah i like your idea of buying
something uh small and uh putting the
rest in mutual funds buying something
that you can live in for
for cash and not having any payments
and um
are any of these rental properties a
nuisance to you would you ever want to
get rid of one
no actually um they cash flow each month
i mean that's basically how i'm living
i'm trying to keep my personal income
separate from my business income and um
so no i don't want to get rid of them
right now
um good i'm sorry i'm a little nervous
what was your question
i just wanted to know about the rental
properties to see what the options are
but
i'm with dave i'm trying to find
somewhere oh i can pay with cash and
that's going to reduce your expenses
which means you can live off a whole lot
less even in your retirement yeah so
that's the goal yeah and invest what
would have been a rental payment or a
house payment now here's the reason to
do that
okay when you buy a piece of property
uh with
100 down obviously in this case
for your retirement years um you're 60
mathematically there's a very high
likelihood you live until 90.
right average death age of a female in
america is 76 but that includes infant
mortality and teenage death and so once
you're a healthy 60 year old 90 is a
high probability statistically speaking
okay
now
obviously none of us ever know exactly
we don't get to decide all that but uh
anyway so now if that means you got 30
years
from today give or take
that you are going to pay
increased rent payments every year for
30 years
it's going to go up every year
or
you're going to take your largest
expense item
in your budget which is housing
and make it stabilize or go away
right
and
the asset is going up in value
so you stabilize
the largest payment you have in your
case you're going to make it a zero but
even if you took out a house payment
in your case
you would stabilize and at least you
know you'd have the same payment
throughout the rest of your life
right and versus rent going up every
year and
the house is going up in value every
year
so that's two major reasons but it adds
a huge level of peace
and stability to be a homeowner as you
head into retirement particularly if the
home's paid for so i'm all in with you
spending
you know the vast majority of this 200
to do that and putting the rest in
mutual funds then commit what was your
old rent payment
out of your income at least if not more
into additional investing ongoing and
let's build that nest egg up yeah i love
this plan and if you have tax advantaged
retirement accounts you can do that with
i know she's a small business owner so
she's lots of stuff she can have some
self-employed you know solo 401k or set
by ras and things of that nature yeah
you can do sapiras you can do solo 401s
that's exactly right and do a roth and
do all of it and put it all in mutual
funds and just see how rich you can
become in the next 10 years
i'll bet you you could have a million
and a half in 10 years in mutual funds
i'll bet you you could get there without
a single house payment in the world
making a hundred thousand dollars a year
i'll bet you it could be done and have a
decent life while you're doing it and
those rentals will go up in value over
time as well and those rents coming to
you not
going to someone else i like this plan
this is going up so just like your
investments go up that is an investment
and those rental
uh
values will go up as well